twinkle twinkle little star
how i wonder what you what wait a minute
why are you twinkling so much whoa
guys that's no diamond in the sky that
looks like a supernova as much as we
love to blow stuff up here on earth no
bombs or pyrotechnics could compare to
the incredible force
of nature's biggest explosion
the supernova as a star
reaches its grand finale and explodes
what would happen to life on earth if
we were close by how far away
from a supernova are we considered safe
could anything survive its deadly
radiation
and what makes supernovae valuable to us
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if a supernova exploded close to earth
before you freak out earth is in a
relatively safe patch of space called
the local bubble this peanut shaped
region of
expanding gas in our milky way galaxy
results from nearby supernova explosions
that occurred
20 million years ago these explosions
helped shape our solar system spreading
gas
dust and heavier elements like uranium
and gold
to earth without these supernovae
we wouldn't have any shiny gold bling or
powerful nuclear reactors
so you can literally count your lucky
stars
okay but are we in danger of any nearby
supernovae on average a supernova will
occur
about once every 50 years in the milky
way
thankfully there are no stars massive
enough to become a supernova within
50 light years of the earth there is
however
one binary star system within 159 light
years of earth
that could potentially put us at risk
binary star systems are type 1
supernovae
this happens in a tumultuous dance
between two stars where
matter is sucked from one star into
another
typically a white dwarf
eventually the white dwarf explodes
resulting in an
epic supernova on the other hand
type 2 supernovae occur when a star runs
out of fuel
and some of its mass flows into its core
over time the core will start to grow
and
get so heavy that it can't withstand its
gravitational force and then
kablooey the core collapses
and a supernova is born
when these explosions occur a powerful
blast of radiation
is spread throughout space that will
kill anything within 50 light years
to put this in perspective our solar
system
is only about two light years wide so
the supernova's blast would be the
distance of
25 of our solar systems in a row if
a supernova occurred as close as 30
light years away
we'd have bigger problems than a
pandemic on our hands
the intense blast of radiation would
carry
a massive influx of high-energy
neutrinos that would
boil any living creature from the inside
out
hope you like your meals poached the
entire earth could be vaporized in just
a fraction of a second if the supernova
was close enough
the shockwave would arrive with enough
force to wipe out our entire atmosphere
and even our oceans the exploded star
would grow
brighter for about three weeks after the
explosion
casting shadows even during the day
even if life survived the superheated
gas
from the supernova would emit deadly
amounts of uv
and gamma radiation these rays would
destroy the ozone layer
leading to the formation of nitrous
oxide smog
we would all have to go deep underground
and embrace our new lives as mole people
to escape the lethal radiation
and poisonous atmosphere unfortunately
there would be an
increase in mutations and deadly cancers
and to top it all off our phytoplankton
which account for almost 50 of all
photosynthetic activity on earth would
die off
phytoplankton is vital to us and can
absorb carbon dioxide from our
atmosphere
without it we'd have a tougher time
breathing
global warming would accelerate even
further beyond our control
and as an essential food source at the
bottom of the marine food chain
a lack of phytoplankton would result in
sea creatures becoming extinct
and eventually humankind would too
so like many what ifs almost everything
dies
no no but there might still be
a few lucky species of extremophiles
that could survive the intense radiation
after a few hundred or thousands of
years
the supernova would leave an impressive
nebula in its wake
at the very least we'd have a fantastic
view in our night sky
well for those of us that can see
maybe these extremophiles would evolve
to have eyes someday and become the size
of humans
well whatever might happen that's a
story
for another what if